beyond um his nickname was bugs
yeah bugs um he was a character a
serious character but he loved his music
he's so handsome beyond brown had just
become a dad when he was stabbed five
years ago i don't know why people behave
in this man i really don't i don't know
why people
i think it's okay
to take something's life
and
just walk away
bjorn's death is one of 350 killings
that have gone unsolved in london in the
last two decades according to figures
obtained by sky news
in march 2017 cctv showed beyond on his
bike in croydon being approached by two
males just before he was stabbed
after his death the grime star stormzy
tweeted woke up to hear a childhood
friend of mine ain't with us anymore
rest in peace bugs
beyond's aunt a former gogglebox star
won't rest
and um
we will catch the people i know i pray
we'll find them
five years on 10 years on i'm not going
to stop searching
the figures also show that more than
half of unsolved killings in london
involve black or asian victims
there's a massive distrust of police not
only in london but across the country in
urban areas and this just distrust is
particularly uh acute in areas where
there's um either large black
communities or or ethnic minority
communities who have had a historic poor
relationship with the police and i think
this does
hinder
policing and investigations
the metropolitan police say that they
assure loved ones that unsolved cases
remain under regular review and they've
renewed their appeal for information
about beyond's murder
lisa dowd sky news